hello everybody and welcome to the
second part of our socket tutorial
series in this video what I'm going to
be showing you guys is a simple what's
known as a port scanner basically what a
port scanner is going to do is exactly
what it sounds like it just scans ports
and it tells you whether or not the port
is open or closed now generally we kind
of have an idea of what the lower ports
are in their situation is going to be
but you can quickly find out if
someone's using something like FTP or if
they're using SSH or whatever and then
obviously port 80 will be open for like
websites and stuff but you can use this
on other people's computers or you can
even use it on your own computer to find
out your own vulnerabilities naturally
with this even though this isn't very as
good port scanner not responsible for
how you decide to use a port scanner I'm
just showing you how they work basically
so with that let's go ahead and we'll
keep se equals we'll keep what I want to
keep the poor we don't need any server
IP we're not I'm going to make this
request we don't need to send any
requests and we don't need a results and
we don't need any of this so now what we
can do here is we can say define P scan
for defining port scan and we can say
the parameter is port then we define
what s define s connect and then we're
going to connect server and then to port
and we've defined server up here
finally what we'll actually what we'll
do here is we'll say try and if that
works we'll return a true accept return
a false or a fault and so what this is
asking basically is we're going to
attempt to connect if we can connect
then we'll make a connection and it's
going to return true for us if we cannot
connect it means the port is not open
and it's going to return a false for us
okay and in fact well now we'll leave
this up here you could put anything up
here you could also allow for like input
or something like that but anyway and
now what we'll do is we'll say for X in
range and we'll say 0 actually we'll say
1 to 26 okay so this will test port
number 1 through port number 25 and then
we're going to say if piece can X print
for X is open so basically what we're
doing is we're passing that x value
whichever of X is in this list of
something what power almost drop those
would anyway um for X in this list of 1
through 26 so it's going to throw that
value through the port parameter of our
piece can function and it's going to
test it and then if P scan X so that
what we're asking here is if true
so if P scan asks either it piece can X
is either returning true or false so we
can ask if true or false what right so
if P scan is true print that port X is
open otherwise we have no else statement
here so nothing else will run so we'll
only tell us if that port is open so
let's go ahead and save and run this
Python programming on that ok and it's
currently running we don't really see
anything occurring at the moment and
really who knows how long this will take
in fact let's go ahead and write a quick
else it's usually like one second to
port so anyway port X
is closed and then we'll add some
exclamation marks make this easy to see
save over okay actually we saw that port
22 is open right away so let's just run
this one last time
and so port 1 is closed for 2 is closed
for 3 is closed so you can see it's very
slow and you know we could run this
through 65,000 ports per thing we're
searching for so obviously this is not
uh the most efficient port scanner it's
pretty poor so generally what people do
is they will thread the report scanner
so I thought I'd be kind of neat to show
you guys port 20 mm to show you guys a
threaded port scanner so you can scan
multiple ports at one time so that's the
next thing I wanted to show you guys is
a quick threaded port scanner and then
we'll actually get back on our on the
path of sockets and learn some more
about sockets so anyways stay tuned for
that as always thanks for watching
things for all the supported
subscriptions and until next time